In this section we'll cover adding the logic to our Blueprint to allow for player input once the sequence has paused.
So back over in our project, let's go ahead and add the logic to our Event Begin Play, particularly between our Pause and Destroy Actor.
So I'm going to go ahead and just disconnect our Destroy Actor, which you can hold down the Alt key and left click, and we'll just move this kind of out of the way.
So after the Pause node, let's go ahead and add a Gate.
And from the Gate node, I'm going to go ahead and move our Enter, so from the Pause we don't want it to enter, we actually want it to toggle.
Now I can hold down Ctrl, click the little noodle here, and move it to our toggle.
And then on the Gate itself, on Enter, let's go ahead and just drag backwards, and I'm going to type in the letter P and start typing in Keyboard.
That should give us the P key.
And essentially what this is going to do is open our Gate or toggle our Gate once the P key is pressed.
And this is what we're going to use to unpause our sequence when the player inputs.
Alright, so from the exit on our Gate, let's go ahead and drag off of this and add a Play.
And what we're looking for is we can do Play Sequence, and it may show up, it may not.
Uncheck Context Sensitive, and there we go, we're going to do our Not Play Sequence, but Play.
And this is just going to continue to play the sequence that we have.
Alright, now from here, our target is still going to be the main sequence.
Now we could drag off of this, we could select it, Ctrl C, or again we can grab our main sequence here, drag it onto the target,
and you'll see that it automatically creates our translator and our variable.
It is essentially the same as what we have here, just we're recalling it and making our graph a little cleaner.
Alright, and then let's go ahead and reconnect after here, our Destroy Actor, we'll hit Compile.
And then one other thing that we need to change real fast is if we leave this logic as is,
the problem is because this is an actor in the level, and we have this P key,
it's not really sure who is pressing this particular key.
So to do that, we're going to go up to Class Defaults, and then over on the side here,
we're actually going to search for Auto Receive Input, and you'll see here it's disabled.
We need to change this to Player 0, and Player 0 is just the default player that is playing the game.
So we'll change this to Player 0, and again doing this we'll make sure that when the P key on the keyboard is pressed,
or any key, that it's recognizing that it's from the actual player, not a random one.
After that, hit Compile and Save.